[Music]
sigh there is nothing easier than
falling in love with no ascent a nail
luckily for us this star is on the rise
so expect to see a lot more of him from
here on out if you're like us you want
to catch every single one of his movies
and by the end of this video there won't
be a single NOAA synteny a roll you're
not aware of watch until the end to find
out which movie actor Jackie Chan will
be directing first time with the things
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up now let's find out what the one and
only nois Antonio is up to Sierra
Burgess is a loser
Sierra Burgess is a loser is a Netflix
original that was released on September
7th 2018 this movie stars actresses
Shannon purser and Christine Frost as
well as actor nois Antonio despite the
fact that Sierra Burgess is a loser was
released after to all the boys of love
before the film was actually shot before
Mercer plays the role of a dorky high
school student who feels ostracized due
to her looks so imagine her surprise
when a super cute and dorky guy named
Jamie starts texting her what first
starts off as a hopeful romance quickly
turns into a catastrophe when Ciara
realizes that her crush is texting the
wrong person unwilling to give him up
Ciara teams up with the hottest girl in
school to catfish Jamie despite the fact
that Noah seems very comfortable playing
the role of Peter Kavinsky into all the
boys of love before he told an AW
reporter that he identified more closely
with his character Jamie his reason
well Peter had more of a cocky nature
tour while Jamie did not swipe it's hard
to imagine Noah Sifton ale being
anything but an angel but hey bubbles
were meant to be burst well guys it
looks like our vision of Santonio just
might be changing by the end of 2018
with the movie swiped well underway it's
only a matter of time before
Centennial's character Lance black is
introduced and let's face it he's
definitely a bad boy this movie takes
place on a school campus and stars many
up-and-coming actors when a big-time
nerd named James finds out that he'll
soon be rooming with a cocky jock he
considers asking the Dean's
switch room before he can do this though
Lance convinces him to reconsider
soon after Lance approaches James with
the opportunity of a lifetime
since James is super intelligent Lance
hires him to program a dating app called
jungle this dating app quickly becomes
the talk of the town but things get
complicated when money women and
business get intertwined before long
lines are crossed and bonds are broken
keep an eye out for this upcoming movie
but keep in mind that noah Santonio
won't be playing the good guy role like
we're so used to seeing miss standin
there's nothing like finding out that
one of your favorite actors is going to
be co-starring with a big-time celebrity
actress camilla mendes is known for
playing the role of Veronica Lodge on
the hit TV series Riverdale the gorgeous
actress will be performing alongside no
Santonio in the upcoming movie the
stand-in Cindy neo and Mendes who play
the roles of Brooks Ratigan and Shelby
pace will definitely be wearing their
love goggles on screen you are gonna go
gaga over this romantic comedy so
imagine this the handsome Brooks Ratigan
is desperately trying to raise money for
his college education since minimum wage
jobs aren't doing the trick he decides
to think outside the box Brooks comes up
with a smart plan to create a dating app
however it's not the kind of dating app
most of us are used to instead it's an
app designed to land people fake dates
to big event
so basically Brooks is getting paid the
big bucks to play the role of a stand-in
boyfriend everything is going as planned
until he meets the beautiful Shelby who
puts a dent in his bulletproof scheme
after pretending to be someone else for
so long
Brooks is relieved to find someone he
can be himself with now doesn't that
sound like the best chick flick ever the
diary little is known about 2019
upcoming movie the diary what we do know
however is that the one and only Noah
settin AO is set to star in the great
film believe it or not the legendary
Jackie Chan will be the writer and
producer of the film so you best believe
that there will be countless fighting
scenes intertwined in its plot the diary
is set to come out sometime in 2019 the
actual date has yet to be confirmed due
to the film still being in
post-production did you know that Chan
is also writing the script for this
upcoming film the Diary is based in the
early
twentieth century which will undoubtedly
place Noah Santonio in some pretty
adorable outfits the story is said to
start off in Shanghai and end in Europe
according to IMDB the plot will consist
of a young man realizing that his life
is missing something so in order to find
happiness once more he returns to Europe
to reunite with the only person he's
ever truly loved the Argentinian actress
Martinez dosel will be acting alongside
notice antonio in the diary are you
excited to see santa now step out of his
comfort zone because we sure are good
trouble there's a new TV series in town
and it's called the good trouble haven't
heard of it yet well that's probably
because it's only gonna start airing
sometime in 2019 this big production is
already filmed a total of 13 episodes
and guess what noah Santonio is going to
be showcased in two of them while this
may not be his biggest role it's
definitely worth the mention it also
gives fans more incentive to tune into
the show this series is about two young
women who moved to Los Angeles with the
hopes of accomplishing their dream sent
in a Oh will appear in episodes swipe
right and one point for under the name
of hey Zeus adams-foster
so basically he'll be related to the to
lead females while he might only be
co-starring in the two episode probably
become a recurring character there's no
way of knowing how big this actor will
get but if things continue the way
they've been going he's bound to reach
the sky in no time so which Noah
Santonio role are you most excited about
let us know in the comments and that's
it for our video we hope you enjoyed the
show see you next time on the things
[Music]